this piece takes a piece put that piece
then takes mine I can't lose my rig
while I'm lagging way behind I'll play
save and wait for an opportunity I won't
let that cheeky monkey make a monkey out
of me you gotta be kidding me hey bobert
what's you up to I'm just with the
monkey huh yeah you don't help I think I
can beat one little monkey how much time
you got
well lucky for you your old pal Matt had
just so happened to be the captain of
his high school chess team they used to
call me the pong star great mark don't
take it that monkey said a trap he wants
me to take it he thinks you're quite a
Santa but check out this fish up you'll
take his piece for free hey the monkeys
got no chance to make a monkey out of me
smartest show in gaming huh hey it was
just a theory
all right kids playtime is over is that
the completionist is the beard look guys
I think I got this okay you do net
let's set a gambit we'll take her by
surprise
not really option you took like half my
guys let's bring in the big guns and
Porsches King - please no the monkey
doesn't further make a monkey out of me
well that's all I got
what but you're the completionist yeah
and I'm completely lousy at chess maybe
we should just let the monkey way oh no
that's okay I appreciate it
but I really truly do not need anyone's
help help somebody need help who is that
hey Jim I made important sweet is that a
monkey no it's a hairy octopus oh you
guys I can translate I'm fluent in
monkey okay I'm pretty sure that's
impossible you know sure fine
why don't we try go ahead
and pretty sure it's our turn
look gentlemen we're here gathered today
as representatives of humanity against a
monkey how long have we been oppressed
two minutes 41 seconds no more no longer
we've been under the monkeys thumb for
too long we can beat this monkey for our
fathers for our forefathers for your
beard for his not beard for whatever
your name is a billion monkeys at a
typewriter may be able to write
Shakespeare but one monkey will not beat
us today I'm a ramble and not know what
I'm talking about all the time but we
can win together as one yeah one of
these pieces has got to do the trick
but how can we beat him I'd recommend
astern it's crazy bananas Sam
but I think we made a monkey out of we
made a monkey out of I they didn't let a
monkey a monkey sore loser Wow Jess
seems pretty intense no kidding
what three in a row son of them I was
gonna say gun all right you know what
let's try this again best out of 12
thanks for watching if you want to see
more of brightly the dog and crystal the
monkey you can catch them in their new
movie Russel madness available March
10th and if you want to see more of the
humans featured in this video I have no
idea where you can find them that's what
the script says but the script is wrong
special thanks to Matt Pat from game
theorist Gerard Khalil aka the
completionist and Ryan and Daniel from
cyndago also thanks to AJ and Peter from
random encounters who pretty much did
everything that you saw in this video
they've done musicals in the past some
of which may star me as Captain Falcon
and finally my name is markiplier and I
beat a monkey at chess today and it only
took three other people I think that's
worth subscribing for and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
you